bonjour à tous merci de nous rejoindre
en direct de la salle des conférences du
sénat pour la séance des questions
d'actualité au gouvernement en première
séance des questions d'actu pour manuel
valls face au sénat qui a basculé à
droite le 28 septembre dernier beaucoup
de questions aujourd'hui sur le projet
de loi terrorisme actuellement examinée
par la haute assemblée mais également le
positionnement du gouvernement face aux
assauts sénat de droit des pays
également des questions toujours et
encore ici sur les collectivités
territoriales
on va en parler dans quelques instants
avec notre premier invité bruno
retailleau le patron des sénateurs ump
bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
vous aller interpeller le gouvernement
sur une question de politique
internationale à savoir la turquie et ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui au kurdistan
autour de la ville de coban et
il y à un sénateur jean-pierre vial un
sénateur ump qui a fait un communiqué
aujourd'hui ils demandent à la france
d'apporter de façon urgente une aide
humanitaire et des armes pour défendre
coban et est-ce que vous soutenez la
démarche de jean pierre valent bien sûr
je suis longuement entretenu ce matin
avec jean pierre c'est une heureuse
initiative il l'a fait et il la mène
comme président du groupe d'amitié
franco syrie et je crois que c'est la
raison de l'interpellation que je ferai
dans quelques instants pour ministre
nous avons tous été choqués profondément
choqués de voir ses chars ses chars turc
masse et immobile spectateur indifférent
d'un drame annoncé d'une ville martyre
coban et à un jet de pierre de cette
ville qui est en train de vivre une
tragédie et la turquie ne fait rien la
turquie ne fait rien alors même qu'elle
est dans la grande coalition alors même
qu'elle est dans l'otan alors même que
c'est une grande puissance régionale
c'est insoutenable mais ce n'est pas une
surprise que là tu allais pas surprendre
les kurdes très franchement très
franchement on a d'un côté lecture et je
sais qu'elle est le passif entre la
turquie et les kurdes mais en face on a
l'état islamique on à la barbarie on a
le troisième totalitarisme je suis j'ai
été le premier parlementaire
c'était rendre en irak j'ai rencontré
j'ai reçu les témoignages qui sont
effroyables insoutenable des réfugiés à
erbil et je peux vous assurer quand on a
vu ces enfants ces femmes ces vieillards
quand on a reçu les récits je peux vous
dire que on s'engage ça fait partie des
convictions de mes engagements et je
pense qu'il faut que le gouvernement
lève en même temps une ambiguïté qui est
terrible vis-à-vis de la turquie
vis-à-vis de sa possible entrée en
europe d'autres faut faire pression
aujourd'hui ce que vous demandez au
gouvernement français c'est de faire
pression sur l'entrée de la turquie en
enjeu je lui demande de chances de faire
pression sur la turquie pour que la
turbie puisse éviter le martyre de koné
et des habitants parce qu'il ya encore
il ya des femmes qui se battent il ya
des civils qui sont encore dans cette
ville qui sont enfermés dans cette ville
mais je demande en même temps de lever
l'ambiguïté est ce que la turquie a
vocation à entrer dans l'union
européenne pour nous non oui à un accord
d'association bien sûr mais non à une
adhésion pure et simple alors que les
américains ne semblent plus préoccupés
par ce qui se passe en irak que par ce
qui se passe autour de la ville de kobe
à nassau si vous avez raison j'ai raison
mais quand on va sur le terrain vous
savez l'état islamique en réalité a
constitué une sorte d'état à cheval
entre la syrie à peu près 25% de la
syrie et un tiers de l'irak donc on ils
ont effacé la frontière entre ces deux
états est en réalité ils sont en train
de s'étendre actuellement en irak il ya
une grosse offensive aussi dont on parle
peu et en même temps en syrie autour de
la ville de cabano pour revenir aux
questions d'actualité cet après midi ici
au sénat bruno retailleau il ya une
question de l'idée du sénateur vincent
capo-canellas sur le positionnement du
gouvernement dans une démarche
constructive et constructif pardon
vis-à-vis du cenajes que ça c'est pas un
peu utopique finalement le gouvernement
de gauche se préoccupent de ce qui se
passe dans un sénat de droite non je
pense que le sénat de droite et
peut-être que paradoxalement ce sera
plus facile pour le gouvernement qui
avant avait soi-disant une majorité de
gauche au sénat mais une majorité qui
s'est très vite fragmenté donc les
choses sont beaucoup plus claires sont
beaucoup plus simples et moi ce que
j'attends
c'est un comportement républicain une
coopération bien comprise évidemment
nous sommes dans l'opposition nationale
mais nous avons la majorité sénatoriale
c'est manuel valls qui répondra
d'ailleurs à cette question qu'est ce
que vous attendez de son premier
discours devant un sénat de droite bien
je l'attend et nous l'attendons surtout
le 28 vous savez gérard larcher lui a
demandé de s'exprimer pour remettre en
perspective la réforme territoriale nous
sommes l'assemblée des territoires et
nous l'attendons sur ce texte là d'une
part pour qu'ils nous donnent du sens
regardez il ya encore eu des
informations sur un report un autre
report éventuel un énième report
éventuel des départementales et des
régionales donc il ya un besoin de
clarification et on va l'attendre
effectivement dans les fêtes sur une
volonté sur sa volonté de dialogue au
moment de la discussion de ce texte à
manuel valls qui vient d'arriver à cela
on vient de le voir sur ces images y est
toujours est ce que oui le flou pour
vous sur cette réforme territoriale
parce que manuel valls il a encore
précisé pas mal de choses notamment
devant l'assemblée des régions de france
la semaine dernière donc pour lui le
calendrier est assez claire à la fois
sur le redécoupage des régions et puis
sur ce qu'il veut faire sur les deux
autour des départements y a que pour lui
qui a pas de flou le flou il est partout
le fou il est sur le calendrier quand
est ce qu'on va voter rendez compte si
les départementales sont au mois de mars
c'est demain on ne connaît même pas les
futurs contours si j'ose dire de
compétences des départements regardez
aussi en matière de la trilogie
départementale puisque on nous a annoncé
la disparition de départements nous a
annoncé que des départements milieu
rural pourrait subsister et que enfin
entre les deux pourrait y avoir des
départements qui seraient des
fédérations d'intercommunalité on y voit
pas clair en huit mois dont deux mois de
vacances le gouvernement a changé
successivement cinq fois deux pieds sur
le département donc voyez qu'il ya
besoin d'une clarification
je suis très heureux que le premier
ministre est accédé à la demande de
notre président gérard larcher pour
cette remise en perspective alors ce
flou sur l'avenir des départements ce
qui explique des rumeurs un toujours sur
le report ou non des élections
départementales et allure ce matin il y
avait une rumeur disant que les
départements là les départementales est
repoussé en décembre 2015 et les
régionales en mars 2016 matignon a fait
un communiqué disons mais bon maintien
on maintient notre calendrier mars 2015
décembre 2015 cours pour les régionales
vous confirmez bah écoutez j'ai rien
n'est confirmé simplement chez lui comme
vous sans doute démentis de matignon et
je pense qu'effectivement c'était qu'une
rumeur mais voyez que plusieurs flou et
plus yade rumeurs donc il faut cette
clarification nous l'appelons et ce sera
le moment le 28 octobre prochain pour le
premier ministre justement de donner sa
ligne mais se fout ça vous sert plutôt
non vous qui allez partir en campagne
pour ces élections départementales des
jeux vous dire ça sert personne parce
qu'on a besoin la france vit un moment
difficile et si on veut redresser la
france y compris pour les collectivités
il faut stabiliser l'environnement voilà
est-ce que vous espérez du premier
ministre lors de son discours devant le
sénat le 28 octobre sur les
collectivités territoriales une
inflexion y compris sur le calendrier
des du découpage des régions on sait que
la deuxième lecture vient au sénat après
le texte sur les compétences est ce
qu'il doit arriver assez rapidement
derrière non je pense que là aussi
gérard larcher à donner cette impulsion
pour que le texte n'arrive qu'à la
mi-décembre qu'on puisse en amont le
préparer ce sera un texte fondamental
important parce que c'est lui qui va
répartir ce qu'on appelle les
compétences les attributions le rôle
entre chacun notamment pour le
département et pour les régions donc il
ya besoin de temps en amont pour le
préparer et certains ici au sénat
réfléchissent à remettre à l'ordre du
jour le conseiller territorial c'est à
dire la fusion entre le conseiller
départemental le conseil régional qui
avait voulu faire nicolas sarkozy est ce
que ça vous semble une bonne piste de
travail en tout cas c'est une des deux
pays sur laquelle nous travaillons et la
semaine prochaine le groupe ump
tranchera entre cdu piste soit la fusion
c'était sale conseiller territorial la
fusion des régions et des départements
soit la piste d'amélioration du texte
proposé par le gouvernement nous
conseiller territorial qui n'avait pas
été très accepter non plus sur le
terrain avait aussi c'est vrai ils
savent où ça vous avez fait perdre le
sénat en 2006 c'est vrai que globalement
il y avait ce climat parce que et moi ça
m'avait profondément à l'époque irrité
j'avais même pas voter le texte
à l'époque dans ce qui m'avait éviter et
hériter et comme d'autres collègues
c'est que on avait l'impression nous les
élus locaux d'être les cibles
privilégiées tout allait mal c'était de
la faute finalement des élus locaux bon
je crois qu'il y avait eu un déficit
avait changé boîte à science a pas
beaucoup
on peut se poser la question est ce
qu'on peut réformer le mille feuille
territorial en france écoutez j'espère
que on aura ici l'occasion dans quelques
jours dans quelques semaines de le
montrer très bien m'écouter merci bruno
retailleau je vais vous laisser
rejoindre l'hémicycle du sénat puisque
dans quelques instants va commencer
cette séance des questions d'actualité
au gouvernement merci d'être venus en
direct sur notre plateau et d'avoir
répondu à nos questions et effectivement
on attend on entend la sonnerie de la
séance retentir on va donc voir un
manuel valls et le président du sénat
gérard larcher quitter ensemble le
cabinet de départ pour se rendre dans
l'hémicycle du sénat c'est la première
fois et bien qu'on va voir les deux
hommes côte à côte depuis les élections
sénatoriales du 28 septembre dernier et
depuis que le sénat a basculé à droite
alors faire un petit point sur les
questions qui vont être adressées au
gouvernement par les sénateurs cet après
midi on va commencer cette séance des
questions d'actu par une interpellation
d'alain richard ancien ministre de la
défense sénateur socialiste et eelv a
posé une question sur le projet de loi
renforçant la lutte contre le terrorisme
c'est le texte qui est examiné cette
semaine par les sénateurs et c'est
bernard cazeneuve qui défend ce texte
qui va lui répondre et puis après il y
aura donc la question bruno retailleau
sur la turquie il y aura également la
première question de françois baroin
tout nouveau sénateur françois baroin
qui était député qui va interpeller le
gouvernement sur le financement sur les
finances des collectivités
territoriales et là c'est manuel valls
le premier ministre qui devrait lui
répondre alors qu'on a pu lire cette
semaine et bien rapport à ces assassins
de la cour des comptes concernant l'état
des finances des collectivités
territoriales manuel valls qui a priori
ici si j'en crois ce qui est prévu
devant les répondre à trois questions
cet après-midi dans l'hémicycle du sénat
d'abord une question sur son attitude
son positionnement par rapport à cette
assemblée deux sénateurs de droite
maintenant ça sera une question du
sénateur udi vincent capo-canellas
manuel valls qui devrait également
répondre à bruno retailleau sur la
turquie et puis il répondra je l'état
leur à françois baroin sur les finances
des collectivités locales alors parmi
les autres thèmes qui vont être abordée
puisqu'il ya dix questions pendant cette
séance des questions d'actualité au
gouvernement on aura une question de
françoise laborde la radical de gauche
sur le virus ebola nous aurons une
question du sénateur vert jean desessard
sur la taxe poids lourds ségolène royal
n'est pas présente cet après midi au
sénat c'est alain vidalis le second
étage le secrétaire d'état chargé des
transports qui devrait répondre à cette
question sur la taxe poids lourds y lire
également une question sur la situation
des autoroutes voilà gérard larcher
ouvre cette séance des questions
d'actualité au gouvernement
à tout à l'heure à ces avec nos invités
pour refaire ensemble cette séance
lors de sa réunion du 9 octobre la
conférence des présidents a décidé
sur ma proposition de reconduire à titre
conservatoire le dispositif retenu
jusqu'à présent pour les questions
d'actualité j'ai invité les présidents
de groupe et le délégué des non-inscrits
a engagé une concertation en vue le cas
échéant d'adapter la répartition des
questions à l'évolution des effectifs
des groupes et de rénover leur
organisation
cette concertation concernera également
les cancers toutes les questions cribles
thématiques et qui ont posé un certain
nombre d'interrogations pour l'heure je
rappelle que l'auteur de la question de
même que là où le ministre pour sa
réponse dispo chaque cas de 2 min 30 il
est important que chacun de nos
collègues puissent passer dans le délai
de temps qui est un parti et qui est
retransmis par voie audiovisuelle la
parole est maintenant à notre collègue
monsieur alain richard pour le groupe
socialiste
merci monsieur le président monsieur
mise de l'intérieur nous terminons à
l'instant pratiquement le débat sur le
projet de loi destinée à lutter contre
le terrorisme et c'est pour moi
l'occasion de saluer l'esprit de
responsabilité et la volonté positive
il s'est exprimé sur tous les bancs pour
appuyer cette démarche législative du
gouvernement au cours de ce débat vous
nous avez signalé un certain nombre de
fêtes reconnu et préoccupant notamment
le nombre de ressortissants français qui
se sont rendus ou qui sont en tentative
de se rendre sur les théâtres
d'opérations terroristes dont plus d'une
centaine sont déjà revenus en france
dans des dispositions d'ailleurs
différentes suivant les uns les autres
et la persistance d'un mécanisme
d'endoctrinement et d'embrigadement qui
continuent à affecter des personnalités
un peu hésitante tout un peu désaxé
une vidéo postée sur youtube hier dont
nous avons tous été
témoin appelle au meurtre de manière
indifférenciée à l'encontre de nos
concitoyens démontrant ainsi de manière
immédiate de façon flagrante la menace
qui continue à se développer de façon
insidieuse sur sur internet
donc au moment où nous concluions
positivement ce débat sur le projet de
loi monsieur le ministre il ya bien sûr
d'autres éléments que la législation
nouvelle l'ensemble des outils
opérationnels dont l'état se dote pour
contrer efficacement cette mesure et des
démarches de coopération avec nos
partenaires et alliés pouvez vous nous
faire une description des moyens de
contre attaque de résistance dont le
pays sous votre autorité se dote pour
lutter contre ce phénomène
répondre
à monsieur alain richard la parole est
un monsieur bernard cazeneuve ministre
de l'intérieur de la parole monsieur
ministre bien monsieur le sénateur je
voudrais avoir commencé par remercier le
sénat pour la qualité du débat que nous
avons eu depuis hier et qui va s'achever
après les questions au gouvernement et
pour le travail très important qui a été
fait par la commission des lois par vous
même comme rapporteur par le reporter
jean jacques pièces pour que ce texte
soit amendé amélioré qui permet d'être
plus efficace encore dans la lutte
contre le terrorisme
d'abord nous voulons prévenir le départ
de ceux qui s'engagent sur le théâtre
des opérations terroristes avec le
risque auxquels ils s'exposent
de la mort sur le théâtre de ses
opérations et le risque auquel s'expose
le pays après leur retour de voir ces
individus qui ont fréquenté toutes
formes de violences et d'actes barbares
être inspiré sur le territoire national
parler seul instinct de la violence qui
explose bien entendu la sécurité des
français nous avons mis en place une
plate forme de signalement pour les
familles qui permet la mobilisation de
tous les prêts faits tous les procureurs
ainsi que de l'ensemble des
administrations de l'état du ressort
territorial de ces familles de ces
jeunes qui sont concernés par le
basculement dans d'éventuelles
entreprises terrorisme et qu'il fallait
aller au delà et la loi prend un certain
nombre de mesures qui sont destinés à
protéger
nos concitoyens du risque terroriste la
première mesure c'est d'éviter les
départs c'est l'interdiction
administrative de sortie du territoire
sous le contrôle du juge administratif
qui est le juge des libertés il fallait
réguler la communication sur internet
parce qu' un certain nombre de groupes
terroristes utilisent internet et les
témoignages des familles nous
l'indiquent pour faire basculer nos
ressortissants dans le terrorisme et
nous avons de ce point de vue là mis en
place un dispositif de sensibilisation
des grands opérateurs là aussi sous le
contrôle du juge pouvant aller jusqu'au
blocage des sites en évitant les risques
de blocage de surblocage et des
dispositifs qui peuvent être
attentatoire aux libertés publiques
nous mettons en place le l'incrimination
entreprise individuelle terroristes pour
que le juge anti terroriste puisse avoir
l'ensemble des incriminations pénales
qui lui permet de faire face à toutes
les situations et enfin nous agissons en
europe par une coopération avec les
services des autres pays et les polices
des autres pays et nous le faisons en
utilisant tous les ressorts du système
d'information schengen un signalement
spécifique combattants étrangers dans le
système d'information schengen la
volonté d'aller au goût de la création
d'un pnr européenne nous irons devant la
commission libe du parlement européen
pour plaider la cause bref en matière de
prévention à travers la loi au plan
européen nous agissons au faire en sorte
que les français soient protégés contre
les risques terroristes merci monsieur
le ministre
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
vincent capo-canellas ce pour le groupe
de l'union des démocrates et
indépendants union sans prise avait la
parole mon cher collègue merci monsieur
le président ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le premier ministre monsieur le
premier ministre à l'occasion du récent
renouvellement d'une moitié du sénat les
élus locaux ont exprimé leur
incompréhension devant un certain nombre
de réformes engagées par le gouvernement
incompréhension devant l'absence d'une
vision claire du devenir de nos
collectivités locales et plus
particulièrement des territoires
inquiétudes marque et singulièrement
quant aux baisses des dotations nous
souhaitons que le sénat soit associé
mieux associer encore à la réforme
territoriale
mais cette inquiétude sur la réforme
territoriale s'inscrit également dans un
cadre plus global celui d'une situation
économique et sociale où malheureusement
les mauvaises nouvelles s'accumulent
appréciation très négative sur le projet
de budget tant de la part du haut
conseil des finances publiques que
l'eurogroupe et peut être demain de la
commission européenne qui doutent de la
réalité des économies attendues
absence de lisibilité sur la politique
du gouvernement quant aux nécessaires
réformes du marché du travail beaucoup
de choses étaient ont été entendus sur
ce sujet sentiment enfin que notre pays
ne s'est pas encore entreprendre la
réforme indispensable pour retrouver sa
compétitivité et sa croissance la france
s'engage dans ce contexte très incertain
avec des déficits accrus vers un niveau
de dette qui franchit déjà la barre des
2000 milliards d'euros cela peut-il
durer
la question n'est pas tant de savoir qui
est fautif ou qui a tort la question
n'est pas encore de renvoyer aux
héritages des uns ou des autres elle est
déterminé comment le pays s'en sort
aujourd'hui je le dis avec gravité il
n'est plus temps je crois de tergiverser
la nouvelle majorité sénatoriale dans
laquelle le groupe eut des us et jouera
tout son rôle s'est engagé dans la voie
d'une opposition lucide donc
constructive sur le mot employé par le
président larcher lui si nous devons
l'être face à l'état du pays et aux
difficultés auxquelles sont confrontés
les français
responsable nous ne saurons si le
gouvernement prend un cap réaliste de
réformes et d'adaptation de notre pays
au monde moderne j'ai pris ministre il
faut parler un langage de vérité certes
mais surtout surtout agir à la hauteur
des enjeux
au-delà de vos déclarations nous vous
jugeront bien sûr aux actes ce sont ces
actes que nous attendons et que nous
souhaiterions voir consolider la
démocratie parlementaire et le dialogue
au sénat entre une majorité et une
opposition peuvent permettre d'améliorer
substantiellement temps la réforme
territoriale que le projet de budget est
d'engager enfin
réformes structurelles dont la france a
besoin êtes vous prêts monsieur le
premier ministre à faire oeuvre utile et
à ouvrir avec le sénat dans sa diversité
le dialogue ou resterez vous tourner
vers les plus à gauche de votre majorité
cela qui bien souvent refusent les
réformes nécessaires à l'adaptation de
notre pays je remercie bien pour
répondre la parole est à monsieur le
premier ministre que je remercie que sa
présence avait la parole monsieur le
premier ministre merci monsieur le
président monsieur le sénateur vincent
capo-canellas ce depuis les élections du
28 septembre dernier il y a en effet ça
ne m'a pas échappé une nouvelle majorité
au sénat et cheveux de ce point de vue
la félicité et salué le président
larcher pour son élection et je ne doute
pas que nous aurons ensemble dans le
respect de nos opinions un dialogue
fructueux et je veux le dire très
clairement ici devant le sénat le
gouvernement entend respecter le sénat
comme je les ai toujours fait à la place
qui était la mienne le sénat quelles que
soient les contours de sa nouvelle
majorité doit poursuivre son travail il
doit continuer à participer pleinement à
l'élaboration de la loi j'ai déjà eu
l'occasion de le rappeler et je suis
heureux de constater que c'est monsieur
le sénateur votre volonté en ce moment
même nous l'avons rappelé il ya un
instant bernard cazeneuve vient de
l'évoquer le sénat examine le texte de
loi de lutte contre le terrorisme et au
vu de la qualité des débats il semble
que vous allez adopter un texte après y
avoir apporté toute votre expertise je
l'avais moi même éprouvé il y a presque
deux ans au moment de l'examen de la loi
antiterroriste et je m'en réjouis c'est
la preuve que sur de nombreux sujets
comme sur la réforme ferroviaire adopté
au sénat à l'été dernier nous sommes
capables d'avancer ensemble nous sommes
capables de prendre des décisions que
nous jugeons utile vous l'avez dit pour
l'avenir du pays vous avez exprimé des
questions les inquiétudes notamment sur
la réforme territoriale
là aussi je souhaite que le dialogue se
poursuive je veux pouvoir expliquer
clairement la volonté du gouvernement
afin que nous puissions débattre
sereinement de l'avenir de nos
collectivités territoriales c'est
pourquoi et sur la proposition du
président gérard larcher je viendrai
devant votre assemblée le 28 octobre
pour une déclaration suivie d'un débat
sur la réforme territoriale sur
fondement de l'article 50-1 de la
constitution et je crois que ce débat
sera utile il permettra je l'espère en
tout cas c'est mon souhait ma volonté
mon intention de donner de la cohérence
et du sens parce que il en faut
l'inquiétude des questions les doutes je
les ai comme vous entendu et cela sera
important juste avant d'aborder le texte
sur la nouvelle carte des régions et
j'espère que cette fois-ci vous en
saisir et pleinement et avant d'aborder
le texte concernant les compétences des
régions que le sénat examinera à la fin
de l'année c'est une réforme majeure et
puis vous l'avais dit dans les
prochaines semaines vous examinerez
également les projets de loi des
finances et de financement de la
sécurité sociale sur l'ensemble de ces
textes j'espère et je souhaite que le
sénat travaille améliore la loi le
gouvernement est prêt en temps des prêts
surtout entendre les projets les
propositions de la majorité sénatoriale
sur l'avenir du pays parce que je crois
qu'il faut éclairer le pays à la fois
sur les économies qu'il faut le faire
elles sont nécessaires sur le projet
européen et sur les priorités que chacun
peut défendre vous avez dit vous même
qu'il s'agit pas de se rejeter cette
responsabilité très bien donc éclairons
le pays sur les propositions pour
l'avenir est en tout cas le gouvernement
rentrer dans ce débat avec la majorité
sénatoriale et sans oublier évidemment
le rôle de la minorité et l'apport de
chacun ici
minorités notamment le groupe socialiste
et le groupe des radicaux de gauche est
au sein du gouvernement je ne doute pas
que les uns et les autres apporteront
leur part leur contribution à la
construction de l'avenir du pays voilà
monsieur le sénateur l'état d'esprit qui
est celui du gouvernement
merci monsieur le premier ministre
la parole est maintenant
au président bruno retailleau pour le
groupe union pour un mouvement populaire
merci merci monsieur le président ma
question à s'adresser à manuel valls le
premier ministre je le remercie
d'ailleurs de l'expression qu'il vient
d'avoir en réponse à l'un de nos
collègues du centre
monsieur le premier ministre il ya
quelques mois c'était le 27 janvier à
ankara le président de la république a
fait une déclaration concernant les
négociations pour l'entrée de la turquie
dans l'union européenne dans cette
déclaration il indiqué je le cite que
cela devait permettre à ce grand pays
moyen-oriental de faire son évolution et
de montrer de quoi il était capable
depuis neuf mois se sont écoulés et nous
voyons en effet de quoi la turquie peut
être capable elle est capable elle est
capable de fermer ses frontières aux
kurdes qui souhaitent aller sauver leurs
frères à quelques dizaines de mètres de
la frontière turco syrienne elle est
capable de fermer ses bases aériennes
aux avions de la coalition alors même
que la turquie fait partie de la
coalition internationale elle est
capable de fermer les yeux sur le drame
sur la tragédie sur le martyre d'une
grande ville syrienne nous avons tous
mes chers collègues en mémoire et à
l'esprit ces images de chars qui sont
immobiles massés à la frontière
complètement silencieux
spectateur indifférent d'un drame
pourtant annoncé ces images du choc
elle nous terrifie même parce qu'elle
vous renvoie d'autres images de
massacres elle nous renvoie aussi à des
témoignages des témoignages que cet été
j'ai pu recevoir à erbil lorsque je me
suis déplacé en irak de réfugiés yazidi
chrétiens ou autres qui sont des
témoignages absolument insoutenable
monsieur le premier ministre dans cette
ville dont je vous parle il y à des
femmes combattantes pas tout il y à des
civils la tragédie est en train de se
jouer ils essaient ses habitants ses
civils d'échapper à une mort sans doute
certaines et ceci à quelques centaines
de mètres de la turquie qu'on ne s'y
méprenne pas la turquie est pour moi un
grand peuple c'est un grand pays c'est
un pays de l'otan c'est un pays qui
frappent à la porte de l'europe mais la
tire cul est aussi un pays qui
actuellement se montre insensible
indifférent à cette tragédie à cette
barbarie de l'état islamique aller un
jour en irak recueillez mes chers
collègues les témoignages qui ont été
faits ils sont effroyables ils sont
absolument insoutenable j'ai soutenu
nous avons soutenu et nous soutenons
comme les efforts de la france mais je
vous pose une seule question est ce bien
raisonnable
monsieur le premier ministre envisage et
l'entrée de la turquie dans l'europe
angela merkel avec nicolas sarkozy avait
bloqué le processus il y a un an vous
avez ouvert aux discussions un chapitre
merci de clarifier la doctrine du
gouvernement à ce moment crucial des
relations internationales merci de votre
attention
pour vous répondre la parole et à je
suis le premier ministre
c'est monsieur le président monsieur le
président bruno retailleau avec
des mots particulièrement fort vous
venez de décrire une situation
dramatique celle que connaît la ville le
covan est une ville frontalière de la
turquie cette ville est le symbole du
martyre d'un peuple les kurdes avec qui
nous avons des liens et bien fort et qui
nous pensons que nous aidons que nous
soutenons peuple en proie à la guerre
civile qui ravage
la syrie et cette guerre civile comme la
france la firme depuis le début depuis
longtemps menace la stabilité de
l'ensemble du proche et du moyen orient
et nous vous voyons bien quelles sont
les conséquences par exemple en irak là
aussi pour les kurdes pour les chrétiens
d'orient pour d'autres minorités comme
les yazidis et nous devons y être
attentif le président la république
ministre de la défense et des affaires
étrangères des parlementaires se sont
rendus sur place vous même pour rappeler
ce qu'il en était et puis nous sommes
évidemment inquiets aussi des
conséquences sur ce pays ami et frère
que le liban a condamné les combats se
déroule sous les yeux de la communauté
internationale
de nombreuses autres villes de la région
en irak comme en syrie livre loin des
caméras une bataille désespérée contre
la progression des forces jadis tout
contre celle du régime de bachar
el-assad je me suis exprimé hier à
l'assemblée nationale sur ce qu'il faut
faire et je veux le redire ici au sénat
la turquie a proposé l'établissement
d'une zone de sécurité et nous y sommes
favorables et nous appelons la turquie à
assumer ses responsabilités et à ne pas
détourner le regard du drame qui se joue
à ses portes à tout faire pour la
protection des populations de coban et
notamment en autorisant l'accès à ses
frontières tous ceux qui sont en
position d'agir sur le terrain doivent
aussi le faire sans délai la france
accroît son soutien à l'opposition
syrienne modérée le rythme des frappes
qui s'est encore intensifiée ces
derniers jours a permis de ralentir la
progression des dash sefra vont se
poursuivre pour permettre aux forces
kurdes de regagner du terrain ce
président vous l'avez rappelé
la turquie qui est un grand pays en pop
up avec qui nous avons aussi une
relation étroite est engagé dans un
processus de négociations avec l'union
européenne ce processus n'est pas lié à
la situation en syrie et en irak c'est
un processus de long terme qui répond à
l'intérêt commun de l'union européenne
et de la turquie le président la
république ou douillet à l'occasion de
sa visite d'état ankara a rappelé notre
position les négociations entre l'union
européenne et la turquie doivent se
poursuivre et le peuple français sera le
cas échéant et le moment venu appelés à
se prononcer sur cette adhésion ainsi
que le prévoit notre constitution nous
ne devons pas envoyé et je termine avec
ses mots et jour répondent très
directement monsieur le président otayo
un message d'isolement mais un message
de responsabilité mais un message de
rassemblement à la turquie qui fait face
à ses frontières à une menace qui
concerne toute l'europe la turquie doit
assumer ses responsabilités ne devons
pas non plus oublier la situation qui
est la sienne est en tout cas c'est le
message à l'ensemble de la communauté
internationale
plus que jamais il nous faut agir
ensemble
merci monsieur pour nice
la parole est maintenant à notre
collègue madame françoise laborde pour
le groupe du rassemblement démocratique
et social européen vous avez la parole
chers collègues merci monsieur le
président ma question s'adresse à madame
la ministre des affaires sociales de la
santé et du droit des femmes elle
concerne l'épidémie du virus ebola qui
sévit actuellement hors de nos
frontières mais qui pourrait se propager
en europe et en france et cette question
a bien pour objet la préparation de la
france comme chacun sait l'épidémie
poursuit sa progression en afrique de
l'ouest on estime à 5000 le nombre des
victimes à ce jour l' oms prévoit cinq
mille à dix mille nouveaux cas par
semaine avant la fin de l'année
l'explosion du nombre de malades est
déjà visible dans les capitales du
liberia du sierra leone et de guinée la
guinée où s'est rendue la secrétaire
d'état au développement et à la
francophonie il ya quelques semaines et
dont le groupe rds salue l'action sur la
scène internationale puisque avec elle
c'est la france qui est en première
ligne sur ce dossier
désormais qualifié de plus grave urgence
sanitaire de ces dernières années par
les présidents obama et hollande la
chancelière merkel et les premiers
ministres cameron et rosie madame la
ministre alors que msf évoque une
situation hors de contrôle dans cette
zone de l'afrique comment ne pas
redouter la propagation de l'épidémie en
france en tout cas il est de votre
responsabilité de l'envisager les
nécessaire contrôle sanitaire dans les
airs et au port seront très certainement
insuffisant et la campagne de
sensibilisation et d'information que
vous avez mis en place il ya quelques
jours et elle aussi bien évidemment
nécessaire pour prévenir et protéger la
population mais elle s'avérera très
insuffisante lorsqu ebola aura frappé
sur notre sol dans ces conditions madame
la ministre quel dispositif est prévu en
cas de découverte d'un premier cas
d'infection sur notre territoire comment
parvenir à l'identifier au plus vite
avant même qu'ils ne deviennent
contagieux
et qu'il ne se propage dans les lieux
publics et comment se passe ce sera
l'entrée de ce patient zéro dans notre
système de soins nos établissements de
santé seront ils en capacité de faire
face pour accueillir et soigner
plusieurs patients infectés
aussi que savez-vous de l'efficacité des
traitements expérimentaux
utilisés dans nos services de soins sans
envisager des stocks proches de se
constituer on s'en souvient pour faire
face à la grippe aviaire
dispose-t-on des quantités suffisantes
alors madame la ministre face à un
risque de contamination du virus ebola
sur notre territoire bien réelle même si
probablement limités la france est elle
prête ou le sera t-elle pour répondre la
parole et à madame ségolène neuville
secrétaire d'état chargé des personnes
handicapées la lutte contre l'exclusion
vous avez la parole d'un ministre merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénatrices et sénateurs
madame la sénatrice françoise laborde je
vous prie tout d'abord d'excusés marisol
touraine ministre des affaires sociales
de la santé et des droits des femmes qui
est actuellement justement à bruxelles
pour une réunion des ministres européens
de la santé sur la situation concernant
le virus ebola vous l'avez rappelé et
marisol touraine a déjà eu l'occasion de
le rappeler également nous sommes à un
moment clé de cette épidémie qui est
majeure nous observons actuellement une
forte aggravation avec une croissance
exponentielle des cas en sierra leone et
au liberia le rixte d'extension régional
des particulièrement élevé et le bilan
est désormais de près de 9000 qu'un avec
plus de 4500 morts probablement très
largement sous estimées sans soutien
international massif et coordonnée
l'épidémie va continuer à s'étendre la
france solidaire avec les pays touchés a
envoyé de nombreux spécialistes depuis
le début de l'épidémie et recrute
actuellement des volontaires pour monter
un troisième centre de traitement en
guinée forestière avec la croix rouge
française et une formation sur place
assurée par médecins sans frontières le
gouvernement salue le courage et
l'engagement des professionnels qui
combat de cette terrible épidémie et
prennent le risque d'être eux-mêmes
infectés comme l'a montré la récente
domination d'une infirmière de médecins
sans frontières fort heureusement guéri
aujourd'hui
alors sur le territoire pour répondre à
votre question madame la sénatrice nous
restons très vigilants et mobilisés
notre système de veille sanitaire est en
alerte avec l'institut l'institut
national de veille sanitaire nous avons
en france les moyens de détecter les cas
d'isoler et de traiter les patients en
cas de doute en cas de fièvre après un
voyage en zone épidémique il faut
appeler le 15 marisol touraine a
récemment présenté des mesures fortes
pour l'information au public un numéro
vert a été mis en place le 0 800 13 00
00 ainsi qu'un site internet est un
point presse hebdomadaire mardi prochain
marisol touraine informera directement
l'ensemble des représentants des
professionnels libéraux et hospitaliers
de santé ainsi que les ordres
professionnels
enfin dès samedi des contrôles auront
lieu à l'arrivée des vols en provenance
de la guinée à paris concernant votre
question plus précise sur l'efficacité
du traitement je prends la liberté de
répondre en tant qu infectiologues
autant que je sache c'est uniquement les
traitements symptomatiques et en
particulier la réhydratation qui pour
l'instant ont fait la preuve de leur
efficacité et ont permis de guérir les
patients qui ont été traités dans les
pays occidentaux contrairement aux
patients africains qui n'ont pas eu
accès à ces réhydratation à ces méthodes
de réanimation vous le voyez madame la
sénatrice la france tient toute sa place
dans la bataille mondiale contre le
virus ebola et garantit la protection de
ses concitoyens mais si le là même où la
parole est elle notre collègue jean
desessard pour le groupe écologie s'il a
deux minutes trente
monsieur le ministre c'est l'histoire
d'une taxe
une taxe acepté par tous mais que
personne n'a le courage d'appliquer
c'est l'histoire de la taxe poids lourds
en août 2009 la majorité des groupes à
l'assemblée nationale vote pour le
principe de la taxe tu votes des députés
ump tous pour moi une voix votes des
députés ps radicaux tous pour moins
quatre voies vote des centristes tous
pour les communistes et les écologistes
abstiennent non sur le principe
non sur le principe mais sur les
modalités d'application
nous pourrons en reparler on avait
peut-être raison
si si il y a eu un tel consensus c'est
que cette taxe poids lourds et vertueuse
elle applique le principe du pollueur
payeur en effet les camions un double
impact sur l'environnement ils usent les
routes et polluent l'atmosphère
davantage que les véhicules individuels
il est donc normal qu'ils des dommages
la collectivité pour cet impact négatif
et ce en fonction de la distance
parcourue
cette taxe à un aspect comportementale
important elle décourage les
comportements les plus pollueurs et
incite les entreprises à revoir leur
mode de production vers plus de
proximité
il est à noter que cette disposition est
appliquée dans l'ensemble des pays
européens comme en allemagne sur les
kilomètres parcourus au comme en grande
bretagne sur la base d'une vignette
cette taxe devait rapporter en france
1,2 milliard d'euros par an sept cents à
760 millions d'euros pour l' agence de
financement des infrastructures de
transport 230 millions d'euros pour
ecomouv
et les sociétés de télépéage 160
millions d'euros aux collectivités
locales et 50 millions d'euros de tva
je pense qu'il faut en finir avec cette
idée de taxation punitive
si l'on considère que l'on punit
lorsqu'on lève l'impôt il faut se
préparer à des lendemains difficiles
jean poiret plus volontiers l'expression
taxation réparatrice et je rappelle la
position globale des écologistes un
transfert des charges basé sur le
travail vers les taxes environnementales
quant à ma question monsieur le ministre
nous avons un manque à gagner de 1,2
milliard d'euros par an et nous avons un
dédit vis-à-vis de la société com offre
d'un montant de 1 milliard
qu'elle taxation alternative va
permettre de récupérer ce manque à
gagner
six nouvelles taxations cette nouvelle
taxation va-t-elle respecter les
principes si l'utilisateur payeur et de
la redistribution aux collectivités et
quand sera t elle mise en oeuvre bien
merci pour vous répondre la parole est
là monsieur alain vidalies secrétaire
d'état chargé des transports de la mer
et de la pêche devait la parole monsieur
le ministre merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur c'est aussi
l'histoire d'une taxe qui pour la
première fois dans notre pays confié à
une entreprise privée l'objet de
recouvrer une taxe c'est aussi
l'histoire d'une taxe qui avait prévu 40
% de frais de fonctionnement
tant et si bien qu'elle apparaissait de
ce point de vue comme étant un peu
irréaliste c'est aussi l'histoire d'une
taxe qui s'appliquerait sur un bon
principe auquel nous souscrivons était
le principe du pollueur payeur
mais pour pouvoir faire voter ce texte
on avait introduit deux dans une bombe à
retardement qui consistait à dire aux
transporteurs les pollueurs mais non
c'est finalement c'est pas vous qui
allez payer car nous allons par un
mécanisme extrêmement compliqué prévues
par la loi prévoir qu'en fait c'est les
chargeurs qui vont à la fin payer et
lorsque les intéressés se sont trouvés
face à face les chargeurs et les payeurs
eh bien ils se sont rendus compte qu'en
réalité ce qui n'était pas les pollueurs
au départ était ce qui in fine est allé
payer d'où un certain nombre de
mouvements vous conviendrez que ce
gouvernement n'est pas beau en choses
dans la signature du contrat que nous
avons été confrontés que nous avons
essayé de bonne foi de le mettre en
oeuvre puisque ça avait été voté tel
était le droit républicain mais qu'il ya
eu une opposition extrêmement forte et
que le gouvernement a été à l'écouté
nous avons essayé de mettre en place un
système qui était le péage transit de
poids lourds ce système aussi s'est
heurtée à une très grande
incompréhension et donc la semaine
dernière nous avons décidé de suspendre
signer dié cette démarche le
gouvernement souhaite à la fois garantir
les revenus de lafitte puisque c'est
extrêmement important pour l'ensemble
des investissements pour pour doux et
puis deuxièmement
participer effectivement très clairement
les transporter au financement des
infrastructures
ce matin j'ai réuni le premier groupe de
travail qui était prévu par l'accord et
j'ai annoncé que le gouvernement
déposerait dans la loi de finances un
amendement deux amendements plus
exactement pour majorer de 4 centimes ce
que les transporteurs perron à la fois
les deux centimes qui vont être payés
par l'ensemble des français et les deux
centimes et qui viendront de la remise
en cause de la part contribution climat
énergie qui était prévu dans la
fiscalité ainsi les transporteurs vont
participer à hauteur de 320 millions qui
s'ajouteront aux 800 millions qui sont
déjà prévues comme recette particulière
pour la fuite le principe est respecté
nous avons une nouvelle disposition et
nous allons poursuivre avec les
transporteurs qu'une discussion pour
parler avec eux de compétitivité pour
parler de social pour parler de jumping
social mais je pense que nous avons
remis en respectant les principes qui
était le nôtre cette perspective de
telle manière qu à la fois les
financements soient garantis et que les
transporteurs soient associés à ces
décisions merci monsieur de milices da
par an et à monsieur jean pierre bosino
pour le groupe communiste républicain
citoyen et la parole au chocolat le ciel
président monsieur le premier ministre
monsieur le ministre
dans la foulée de la question et la
réponse précédente
le gouvernement est à la recherche de
nouveaux financements à la suite de la
disparition de cette écotaxe est une
évidence s'impose à privatisation des
autoroutes qui a amputé l'état d'une
ressources conséquentes elle a constitué
cette privatisation une faute politique
et financière reconnue largement y
compris dans cet hémicycle pourtant lors
de la discussion de notre proposition de
loi de renationalisation de ces
concessions le 19 juin dernier seul le
groupe écologiste a soutenu ce projet
vous semblez aujourd'hui reconnaître que
cette privatisation a permis la création
d'une rente privé très lucratif
s'accompagnant d'une hausse continue des
péages et des suppressions d'emplois le
manque à gagner pour les finances
publiques est de l'ordre de 37 milliards
d'euros d'ici 2032 autant d'argent qui
aurait dû financer l'amélioration des
infrastructures et donc des conditions
de transport des usagers cet argent va
aujourd'hui dans les poches des
actionnaires de vinci eiffage et autres
il est temps que cesse ce racket le
gouvernement évoque la possibilité de
renégocier ses concessions pour mettre
fin à la conterie pour mettre à
contribution ses sociétés vous le savez
et plusieurs ministres l'ont rappelé
juridiquement ce projet est difficile en
effet les contrats sont bien ficelés et
les efforts demandés aux
concessionnaires se traduiront par des
exigences de compensation nous craignons
donc que limiter le débat la seule
renégociation condamne les pouvoirs
publics à l'inaction nous affirmons
alors que seule la nationalisation
importerait la clarté politique mais
aussi la sécurité juridique de la même
manière nous ne pouvons admettre que
l'écotaxe qui combler le déficit liée à
la privatisation des autoroutes soit à
son tour remplacé par une augmentation
de la fiscalité sur le diesel comme vous
venez de le rappeler faisant peser une
nouvelle fois principalement le
financement des revendications du
patronat sur les ménages est ce cela une
politique de gauche votre ministre de
tutelle un premier d'aller jusqu'au bout
des décisions à prendre et donc la
question allez vous donc enfin envisager
une renationalisation des concessions
autoroutières et ne nous dit pas qu une
telle décision aggraverait les finances
publiques vous le savez l'investissement
public a toujours été le gage des
progrès économiques et sociaux
contrairement à la philosophie du
nouveau plan de libéralisation porté par
bercy m merci pour vous répondre la
parole et à monsieur alain vidalis
secrétaire d'état chargé des transports
de la mer et de la paix de la parole
ministre merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur les conséquences de
la privatisation des autoroutes en 2005
par le gouvernement de monsieur de
villepin ont fait l'objet d'une première
observation par la cour des comptes en
2008 qui je cite regrettait que le prix
de cession des autoroutes et était
inférieur à certaines évaluations le 24
juillet 2013 la cour des comptes a
présenté un rapport spécifique sur les
relations entre l'état et les sociétés
concessionnaires d'autoroutes
la cour constate et je cite des rapports
déséquilibré au bénéfice des sociétés
concessionnaires des hausses de tarifs
de péage nettement inférieur supérieure
à l'inflation et le caractère
contestable des hausses tarifaires issus
des contrats de plan le 18 septembre
dernier l'autorité de la concurrence a
souligné
je cite la rentabilité exceptionnelle
des sociétés concessionnaires largement
déconnectés de leur coût est
disproportionnée par rapport aux risques
en l'assimilant à une ronde l'autorité
de la concurrence relève pour 100 euros
de péage payé par l'usager entre 20 et
24 sont du bénéfice net pour les
concessionnaires l'autorité formule 13
recommandations dont les deux suivantes
améliorer les conditions de la
concurrence dans les appels d'offres des
concessionnaires et introduire des
clauses de revel réinvestissement et de
partage des bénéfices au bénéfice de
l'état le gouvernement a déjà limiter au
maximum la hausse tarifaire en 2014
suite au rapport de la cour des comptes
puisque l'augmentation a été de 1,15
pour cent contre 2,3 pour cent en
moyenne jusqu'en 2012 nous avons
augmenté de 100 millions la redevance
domaniale dès 2013 soit une augmentation
de 50% actuellement vous le savez une
mission d'information de l'assemblée
nationale travaille sur cette question
et devrait publier son rapport vers le
15 novembre le gouvernement entend tirer
toutes les conséquences de l'avis de
l'autorité de la concurrence
une première rencontre avec les sociétés
d'autoroutes est intervenu cette semaine
sous la présidence et l'autorité du
premier ministre une chose est certaine
le gouvernement ne restera pas sans
tirer les conséquences de cet avis il
fera connaître son choix à l'issue de la
concertation engagée et avec l'objectif
de préserver les intérêts de l'état des
usagers et de favoriser l'investissement
créateur d'emplois merci monsieur le
ministre la parole et a23 collègue
yannick vaugrenard pour le groupe
socialiste avait la parole mon cher
collègue merci monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse à madame la ministre
ségolène neuville madame la ministre mes
chers collègues la journée mondiale du
refus de la misère sera célébrée demain
vendredi 17 octobre comme chaque année
depuis 1987 journée reconnue par les
nations unies depuis 1992 à cette
occasion vous avez accepté monsieur le
président larcher de recevoir ce mini
pour les remercier de leur formidable
engagement les responsables nationaux
des associations caritatives et
humanitaires de notre pays prolongeant
ainsi la volonté de jean pierre bel
je tiens à vous remercier pour cette
belle logique de continuité républicaine
nous avons sur les bancs de notre haute
assemblée des différences et divergences
d opposition elles peuvent être vives
mais c'est le signe d'une démocratie
vivante pour autant il nous arrive
notamment sur des sujets de portée
internationale de nous réunir lorsque
l'inacceptable est à nos portes menace
notre sécurité ou encore les droits de
l'homme mais mes chers collègues la
pauvreté la misère c'est aussi une
violation des droits humains la pauvreté
et la plupart du temps sont
insupportables et réalité c'est une
violation des droits humains des hommes
et des femmes qui n'utilisent pas leurs
droits sociaux en général et ceux liés à
la santé en particulier parce que les
démarches sont trop lourdes qu'il faut
répéter sans cesse et à des
interlocuteurs différents sa triste
histoire c'est encore une atteinte aux
droits humains leur trophée crainte
stigmatisation au lieu d'une main tendue
c'est également une atteinte aux droits
humains dans un pays comme le nôtre nous
devrions n'ont pas considéré que ces
hommes ces femmes ces enfants touchés
par la misère sont des assistés mais
plutôt des ayants droit de notre
république
trop souvent le non-recours sert de
variable d'ajustement budgétaire
inadmissible alors qu'il devrait y avoir
une volonté unanime pour sanctuariser
les budgets liés à la lutte contre la
pauvreté ce qu'il ya de scandaleux dans
le scandale c'est qu'on s'y habitue
écrivait avec juste raison simone de
beauvoir je souhaite mes chers collègues
que nous soyons individuellement et
surtout collectivement les porte-voix de
la détresse des sans voix madame la
ministre le 21 janvier 2013 un plan
contre la pauvreté fut adoptée pouvez
vous nous dire les évolutions constatées
par rapport aux objectifs qui avait été
indiqué quelle nouvelle est
indispensable étapes sont envisagées
pour aller au delà et ainsi avoir
l'ambition d' éradiquer la pauvreté dans
notre pays des droits de l'homme je vous
remercie merci mon cher collègue la
parole est à mme ségolène neuville
secrétaire d'état chargé des personnes
handicapées de la lutte contre
l'exclusion savez la parole à la
ministre merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur yannick vaugrenard
le 17 octobre demain sera effectivement
la journée mondiale du refus de la
misère alors monsieur le sénateur je
sais combien la lutte contre la pauvreté
vous tiens personnellement à coeur et je
voudrais saluer ici le travail que vous
avez réalisée sur le sujet ainsi que la
qualité des débats qui ont eu lieu ici
même sur l'ensemble des bancs de cette
assemblée à l'occasion de la
présentation de votre rapport il y a
quelques mois le gouvernement tout
entier est engagé dans la lutte contre
la pauvreté le plan pluri annuel contre
la pauvreté et pour l'inclusion sociale
adoptée en janvier 2013 grâce entre
autres au travail de ma prédécesseure
marie-arlette carlotti mobilise tous les
ministères son budget a été entièrement
préservée c'est un choix fort de ce
gouvernement le plan pluri annuel
comprend des mesures concrètes et je
veux vous en citer quelques unes d'abord
pour améliorer le pouvoir d'achat des
familles fragiles le rs1 est augmenté
chaque année de 2% en plus de
l'inflation
le complément familial est augmenté de
10% par an ce qui équivaut à 200 euros
par an pour les familles les plus
fragiles ainsi que l'allocation de
soutien familial qui fait l'objet d'une
hausse de 5% par an ce qui équivaut à
100 euros par an pour les familles
également les plus fragiles ce plan
contient également des mesures concrètes
pour l'hébergement et pour le logement
avec 7000 nouvelles places d'hébergement
et avec en 2013 cent dix sept mille
nouveaux logements sociaux et en 2014
134000 je veux aussi cité les mesures
concrètes pour aider les familles à
payer leurs factures d'énergie avec le
chèque énergie et pour favoriser l'accès
aux soins avec l'élargissement de
l'accès à l'aide à la complémentaire
santé et à la couverture maladie
universelle ce qui à terme aboutir à à
750 mille nouveaux bénéficiaires de ces
aides quant à l'accès à l'alimentation
pour les plus démunis les crédits
européens ont été confirmés tandis que
les crédits nationaux sont consacrés à
la d'alimentaire sont à hauteur de 32
millions d'euros pas en ce plan comprend
enfin des mesures pour les jeunes avec
les emplois d'avenir mais aussi la
garantie jeunes qui pour le moment
concerne dix départements mais qui en
2015 en concernera 40 et donc je vous
confirme l'extension de la garantie
jeunes enfin je veux vous dire aussi
monsieur le sénateur car je sais que ce
sujet vous est cher que nous continuons
à travailler sur la simplification des
formulaires et des parcours
administratif pour faciliter l'accès aux
droits de tous et nous ferons
prochainement des annonces sur ce sujet
nous ne pourrons pas éradiquer la
pauvreté vous le savez mais il est de
notre devoir de la combattre et comme
l'a dit le président de la république la
pauvreté est une humiliation pour la
république
l'ensemble du gouvernement est mobilisé
et tous les engagements du plan seront
tenus merci madame la ministre parle est
un monsieur françois baroin pour le
groupe union pour un mouvement populaire
vous avez la parole du sud à revoir
merci
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
et porte sur la préparation budgétaire
et les enjeux de la loi de finance
l'économie française vous le savez mieux
que quiconque les malheureusement cale
sèche les causes sont nombreuses elles
sont identifiées elles sont au long
cours depuis de nombreuses années parmi
ces causes il ya un environnement
international très incertain sur lequel
le gouvernement n'a n'a pas de prise ou
pas directement la situation en russie
la problème des mollahs qui a été évoqué
par une amie secrétaire d'état à la
santé la question syrienne
l'environnement général le début d'un
point d'inflexion sur la situation
économique allemande qui crée évidemment
beaucoup beaucoup de questions et
d'interrogations sur cette base vous
avez préparé un budget qui vise et c'est
heureux à engager un processus que
personne de sérieux désormais deux
contestent d'une réduction des dépenses
publiques et d'une réduction des
déficits même si les objectifs ne sont
pas ce qui était annoncé il ya deux ans
dans les sources de dépenses elles sont
connues également il y en a 3 il ya
celle de la sécurité sociale de l'ordre
de 600 milliards il ya celles de l'état
hors dette et pensions de l'ordre de 280
milliards et puis à celle des
collectivités locales de l'ordre de 230
milliards c'est à dire que la source de
dépenses des collectivités locales est
la plus faible par rapport à la totalité
des sommes de dépenses publiques et
c'est sur ces dépenses là que les
mesures que vous proposez dans le cas de
cette loi de finances 2015 porte
l'effort le plus important et c'est
toute la problématique qui nous
interpelle qui nous interroger sur
lequel nous essaierons en responsabilité
en conscience au sein de la majorité
sénatoriale de vous formuler des
propositions mais je veux vous alerter
monsieur le premier ministre sur la
réalité de l'effort qui est demandé aux
collectivités locales vous avez été l'un
des nôtres d'ailleurs comme maire et
vous savez l'exigence et la difficulté
et d'arbitré dans ses budgets mais
demander aux collectivités locales dans
un discours d'ailleurs qui flatte un peu
une forme de populisme rond dans les
collectivités locales responsables d'une
partie de la gabegie de la dépense
publique ce qui n'est pas acceptable
demandez demandé aux collectivités
locales demandé aux collectivités
locales et au bloc communal notamment de
porter l'équivalent de 38 milliards
d'effort c'est à dire une suppression de
30 % des dotations d'équipement et de
fonctionnement c'est absolument
intenable ma question est double
monsieur le premier ministre avez vous à
votre disposition des études précises
sur l'impact en termes de croissance de
disparitions d'emplois dans le bâtiment
les travaux publics toutes les filières
artisanales amont et aval qu'elles
peuvent induire ce type de mesures ma
deuxième question elle est peut-être
plus sous forme d'ouverture êtes vous
prêt vous même à piloter un groupe de
travail de remise en cause d'un
calendrier de participation d' efforts
des collectivités locales non pas pour
être sur les trois ans à 38 milliards
mais sur un terrain qui sera acceptable
pour touche pour les collectivités qui
porteront la part de l'effort et pour
l'état qui doit montrer le chemin ni la
parole à monsieur le premier ministre
vous avez la parole monsieur le premier
ministre merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre monsieur le le
sénateur je vois que vous êtes
pleinement dans dans vos fonctions et
peut-être même dans nos futures
fonctions en prenant ainsi la défense
des collectivités
territoriales riches et des informations
au passage au ministère de l'intérieur
ne permet d'avoir des éléments et
quelques fiches monsieur karoutchi
plus sérieusement
oui il faut faire un effort et l'effort
qui est en train d'être présenté à
l'assemblée nationale et qu'il le sera
prochainement ici au sénat par michel
sapin et christian eckert et est connue
50 milliards sur trois ans un effort
important sans précédent 20 milliards
pour l'année 2015 avec un effort demandé
important pour l'état d'abord pour
l'assurance maladie et pour les
collectivités territoriales
aucun d'entre vous m'ont entendu ici
entendu un membre du gouvernement en
charge de ces questions s'en prendre aux
collectivités territoriales nous
connaissons ici toute la légitimité la
légitimité des élus et personnes d'entre
nous ne sont rares dans ce populisme
même si nous le savons les français sont
très attentifs et c'est normal vu les
efforts qu'ils font depuis des années
ils sont très attentifs à la question de
la de la dépense publique pour l'état
comme pour les collectivités
territoriales
d'ailleurs les mêmes qui
prennent pour exemple pour critiquer le
gouvernement les conclusions les travaux
de la cour des comptes concernant l'état
sont les mêmes qui fustige le récent
rapport de la cour des comptes
concernant la dépense des collectivités
territoriales donc vous avez raison il
faut y travailler sérieusement faire les
études d'impact nécessaire et je suis à
l'écouté non seulement des élus serait
présent congrès l'association des maires
de france comme devant tous les congrès
demain je serai à chambéry mme ce soir
mais demain devant le congrès le
rassemblement des élus de la montagne
dans quelques jours devant les
départements de france pour entendre
pour convaincre aussi et je suis aussi à
l'écouté de l'ensemble des
professionnels du bâtiment et des
travaux publics je les dis jeudi dernier
à lille devant la convention des
intercommunalités je souhaite que les
élus qui innove qui investissent et qui
développent leur territoire soit
encouragée et aidée et au delà des
économies que nous demandons à la nation
la de l'effort de la nation consent pour
se tenir les entreprises pour les rendre
plus compétitives au delà des réformes
de structures qui sont indispensables
l'investissement et la préparation de
l'avenir sont nos priorités donc nous
devons nous appuyer sur les
collectivités territoriales les contrats
de plan y contribueront ils mobiliseront
plus de 12 milliards d'euros de crédits
de l'état sur les territoires sur six
ans et près d'un milliard 990 millions
d'euros seront consacrés au volet
territorial de ces contrats de plan ils
sont entièrement financées et alain
vidalies je crois encore donné
suffisamment d'éléments tout à l'heure
pour montrer qu'ils sont en effet
totalement financé j'ai aussi indiqué
qu'à l'occasion du débat sur le projet
de loi de finances je souhaite que nous
puissions examiner ensemble des
solutions complémentaires pour soutenir
l'investissement local des amendements
ont été déposés et adopté en commission
à l'assemblée nationale comme je l'avais
annoncé la hausse du fctva ne sera pas
compensée au sein des concours aux
collectivités en 2015 et 1 666 millions
d'euros qui seront sanctuarisés et le
gouvernement donnera également son
accord à la majoration du taux de fctva
qui a été proposée par les
parlementaires enfin certains propos de
la création d'un fonds de soutien à
l'investissement local je suis ouvert à
ce que nous poursuivons la discussion
sur la création de ce fonds est donc
monsieur baroin monsieur le ministre je
suis ouvert à toute proposition qui nous
permettra d'avancer ensemble pour
préserver l'investissement des
collectivités territoriales le rôle
essentiel que ces collectivités jouent
pour préserver le pacte républicain et
sociale et en même temps je serai
attentif vous comprendrez à léquilibre
de nos comptes et aux engagements de la
france et moi je suis prêt à engager un
débat je le disais tout à l'heure le
plus ouvert d'autant plus que je
constate je crois pas que ça vient de
vous qui y compris parmi un certain
nombre de vos amis politiques beaucoup
proposent également une réduction
drastique des dotations de l'état et
notamment pesant sur l'état et les
collectivités territoriales
et cette volonté de réduire à 100 ou 150
milliards la dépense publique moi je
souhaite qu'on m'explique comment sur
qui cela doit peser ça c'est le bon
débat à voir mais en tout cas je vous ai
entendu propose que nous nous
rencontrions vite pour voir dans quelles
conditions oui nous pouvons travailler
ensemble pour préserver parce que c'est
ça qui est essentiel l'investissement
des collectivités territoriales merci
monsieur le premier lieu portelli pour
le groupe union pour un mouvement
populaire
vous avez la parole en vous demandant de
contracter les questions les réponses
pour permettre monsieur patriat de poser
sa question merci monsieur le président
ma question s'adresse ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre de
l'éducation nationale de l'enseignement
supérieur et de la recherche
hier les maires de très nombreuses
communes de france ont dû prendre en
charge des enfants des écoles
maternelles et élémentaires
durant une demi journée il semblerait
que cela doive se renouveler encore
trois autres demi journée durant l'année
chaque fois pendant le temps scolaire
afin de permettre aux enseignants de se
rendre à des réunions de concertation
sur l'avenir des programmes
madame le ministre les maires ont
accompagné la mise en place des nouveaux
rythmes scolaires malgré les très
grandes difficultés que cela engendre et
même s'il n'y adhèrent pas tous en dépit
des problèmes d'organisation et de
financement dont la lecture du projet de
loi de finances montre qu'ils iront
croissants du fait du désengagement
programmé de l'état ils ont assuré au
mieux l'accueil des enfants et le
fonctionnement de l'école le mercredi
matin ou le samedi matin
demandez maintenant au maire de gérer
comme ils le pourront la prise en charge
des enfants pendant le temps scolaire
alors que la consultation interne engagé
par votre ministère peut et même doit se
dérouler sur le temps de service des
enseignants qui comporte rappelons le
outre les heures devant élèves 108
heures dédiées à diverses actions dont
la concertation cela est inacceptable
les maires ainsi que la mf vous l'a
rappelé à plusieurs reprises
refuse de se substituer à l'éducation
nationale pour l'exercice de ses
responsabilités
ils demandent que le mode d'organisation
dé concertation avec les enseignants
soient revus afin qu'elles se déroulent
partout en dehors des heures scolaires
des enfants ils demandent que l'état
assume les conséquences de ces choix
unilatéraux s'il persiste à maintenir
ces réunions durant le temps scolaire et
dans la mesure où les communes
assureront l'accueil des enfants ne
serait ce que pour permettre à leurs
parents de travailler il incombera au
ministère de l'éducation nationale de
rembourser aux communes les frais de
personnel engagé pour pallier à cette
carence
enfin les maires demandent qu'une
concertation s'ouvre avec l'état et
entre l'état et les communes afin que
sur tous ces sujets les communes ne
soient pas toujours placés devant le
fait accompli et que l'état ne se
défausse pas sous les communes pour
acheter la paix sociale avec ses
enseignants
pour vous répondre la parole et à madame
geneviève fioraso secrétaire d'état
chargée de l'enseignement supérieur et
de la recherche de la parole d'un
ministre
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur et portelli je prie d'excuser
tout d'abord najat vallaud belkacem qui
est en partance pour la guyane or
l'école française comme vous le savez
souffre de performances insuffisantes de
ses élèves le gouvernement a donc lancé
un travail de réécriture du socle commun
de connaissances de compétences et de
culture pour qu'il devienne le programme
général de la scolarité obligatoire
le conseil supérieur des programmes a
rendu public son projet de rédaction que
les ministères de l'éducation nationale
engagé une vaste consultation sur ce
texte ainsi que sur les programmes de
l'école maternelle
c'est un enjeu qui nous concerne tout ce
qui concerne l'ensemble de la nation et
son avenir
les jeunes c'est pourquoi le ministre de
l'éducation nationale de l'enseignement
supérieur et de la recherche a souhaité
que toutes les parties concernées dans
la mise en oeuvre de ce socle
participent à cette réflexion commune la
consultation qui a été lancé est d'une
ampleur exceptionnelle et inégalée
d'ores et déjà ce sont les deux tiers
des académies qui l'ont organisé pour
recueillir les avis et les propositions
depuis plus de huit cent mille
personnels d'enseignement d'éducation et
d'encadrement dans ce cadre dans les
écoles et des collèges une demi journée
banalisée a été ouvert être organisé
afin de permettre au personnel de se
réunir et d'échanger ceux qui n'ont pas
le temps de faire sur le temps scolaire
ces réunions associé non seulement les
enseignants du primaire et du secondaire
les personnels de la vie scolaire mais
aussi les agents territoriaux
spécialisés des écoles maternelles les
atsem et qui relèvent vous le savez du
personnel communal d'autres demi
journées nationales ont d'ores et déjà
été ainsi organisées dans le passé pour
des débats traversant l'ensemble des
secteurs de l'éducation nationale par
exemple lors des assises de l'éducation
prioritaire à l'automne 2013 de la
réforme du lycée en 2010 du débat
national sur l'avenir de l'école en 2003
ou de la consultation des programmes en
maternelle et en élémentaire en 2002 ou
encore de la réforme du collège en 2001
1 il est vrai que cette modalité vous
l'avait dit et nous l'avons entendu
implique de fait l'absence d'accueil des
élèves dans les écoles et les collèges
et les difficultés qui ont pu être
causés aux élus aux parents n'ont pas
été ignoré c'est pourquoi là où elle se
manifeste le ministère invité les
recteurs à consulter à nouveau tous les
intéressés afin de retenir la date qui
serait la plus adaptée pour tous
notamment en secteur rural ou semi rural
d'ores et déjà dans 20% des académies la
date de consultation a ainsi été modifié
avec l'accord de l'ensemble des acteurs
concernés si l'organisation de ces
journées a peut être contestées
certaines académies sur la base de leur
organisation dans certains cas sur le
temps scolaire le juge administratif a
pu exprimer qu'il n'y avait pas urgence
à suspendre ces demi journées de
consultations cependant comme je voulais
déjà dit les modalités d'organisation à
l'avenir sont susceptibles d'évoluer en
tenant compte des réserves exprimées
vous avez été entendu
mais s'il même liste la parole et à
notre collègue françois patriat pour le
groupe socialiste avait la parole merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre
relancer l'apprentissage s'est relancé
l'emploi et redonner espoir à beaucoup
de jeunes de notre pays c'est un constat
partagé par tous or vous le savez
aujourd'hui l'apprentissage va plutôt
mal loin des 500 milles apprentis le
nombre d'apprentis a été en baisse en
2013 et en 2014 que plusieurs facteurs
que je n'évoquerai pas ici il reste que
le chef de l'état a réuni le le 16
septembre les assises de l'apprentissage
où il a expliqué ce jour là que
conscient des difficultés que
rencontrent au secteur hélas les données
de ma les moyens avec 200 millions
d'euros avec les fonds européens pour
relancer l'apprentissage de deux façons
de deux façons la première monsieur le
premier ministre vous qui l'avez annoncé
100 millions à la fois pour les pubs
pour les filières et pour accompagner
les apprentis la deuxième 80 millions
pour accompagner les capacités
d'hébergement et de nouvelles filières
d'apprentissage de surcroît le 19
septembre mais chez premier ministre a
annoncé qu'il y aurait une prime pour
les apprend pour les employeurs
d'apprentis de 1000 euros jusqu'à 250
employeurs à prendre en loi et qui
s'ajouteraient aux mille euros pour les
employeurs qui ont moins de 11 salariés
c'est donc une prime de 2000 euros pour
ceux ci et 1000 euros pour les autres ma
première question c'est est-ce que cette
dispositif s'applique dès maintenant
deuxième question très bon monsieur le
président elle concerne les normes
dissuasif sécuritaire envers les
employeurs qui aujourd'hui avec les
apprentis mineurs ont des difficultés à
pouvoir les faire travailler parce qu'il
ya des normes sécuritaires trop
draconienne est il possible comme s'y
engage et françois rebsamen dernièrement
au territoire de bourgogne de faire
évoluer ses hors norme puisque un
apprenti peintre puisse monter sur une
échelle jusqu'à 3 mètres de haut ne soit
pas dissuadé par là même de s'engager
dans une filière qui est convenant le
est une filière dalloul je vous remercie
pour répondre la parole est à monsieur
jean marie le guen secrétaire d'état
chargé des relations avec le parlement
vous avez la parole monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs je
le sénateur françois patriat je vous
prie d plus d'abord d'excuser l'absence
de françois rebsamen qui est retenu à
luxembourg dans un conseil des ministres
de l'emploi
l'apprentissage vous le savez monsieur
le sénateur est une priorité tous les
acteurs en sont convaincus mais malgré
cette reconnaissance et des résultats
excellents termes d'insertion
professionnelle que vous avez rappelé le
nombre d'apprentis a malheureusement
diminué de 8% en un an et le
gouvernement ne se résignent pas à cette
situation pour remédier le prix de la
république a lancé une grande
mobilisation pour l'apprentissage en
réunissant les partenaires sociaux le 19
septembre dernier à l'elysée et le
budget que nous discuterons dans
quelques jours eh bien nous vous
proposerons 300 millions d'euros
supplémentaires consacrées à
l'apprentissage qui permettra dès le
début 2015 monsieur le sénateur de
remplir les obligations dont vous avez
parlé les possibilités de vous avez
parlé 1000 euros pour les entreprises de
moins de 50 2000 euros pour les tpe
notamment
il y à aussi à l'occasion de ce sommet
annoncé un salon de mesures qui
renforceront l'attractivité
de l'apprentissage et nous sommes
maintenant à la phase de mise en oeuvre
de ces dispositions comme vous le
soulignez la réglementation récente à
simplifier le système de dérogations
mais pose des difficultés de lisibilité
pour le secteur du bâtiment notamment et
de la mise en oeuvre pour les métiers
qui nécessitent des travaux en hauteur
en effet si la possibilité pour des
mineurs en formation de travail en
hauteur a été conservée sous prétexte
d'une dérogation de l'inspection du
travail il a été exigé des moyens de
protection collective andorre certains
cas les équipements de protection
individuelle sont utilisables est
suffisant mais pas les protections
collectives d'où un certain nombre de
situations d'impossibilité à faire
travailler par exemple les apprenti
couvreur aussi le gouvernement pour le
gouvernement il importe de maintenir
constant le niveau de protection des
jeunes il est nécessaire de mettre à
disposition des employeurs notamment
ceux qui n'ont pas de salariés recrutant
un apprenti une offre de services pour
les aider dans leurs démarches
gouvernement souhaite apporter des
réponses à ces questions en concertation
avec les organisations syndicales et
professionnelles
le ministre du travail saisira le
conseil d'orientation sur les conditions
de travail en novembre et nous aurons
une réponse le plus rapidement possible
merci monsieur le ministre
à merci monsieur le premier ministre
merci mesdames et messieurs les
ministres je vais maintenant suspendre
la séance elle sera reprise à 16h15 pour
la suite de la côte discussion du projet
de loi adopté par l'assemblée nationale
après engagement de la procédure
accélérée renforçant les distincts sur
ces questions d'actualité au
gouvernement première séance des
questions d'actualité
présidée par gérard larcher depuis le
retour du sénat à droite on se retrouve
dans quelques instants pour refaire
ensemble la séance